Це я роблю таку заготовку.
Я мушу їх сокирою спершу обтесати так,
щоб було трохи круто.
Нас колись називали «прокурі́вські лежа́шники».
Бо казали не «ложка», а «ле́жка».
І називали «прокурі́вські лежа́шники».
[сміється]
Але це колись, раніше, тому що тільки
в Прокураві робили ложки, більше ніде.
Зараз я буду виточувати таку...
болванку.
Потім буду розрізати, а потім все решта.
Переважно бук, явір (от я роблю з яблуні),
з черешні роблять.
Такі от дерева фруктові [використовують].
З горіха не підходить, тому що коли його намочити,
він має такий неприємний запах.
Я можу зробити 40 чи 50 ложок, залежно від розміру.
Якщо великі, такі, як ці, то 40 ложок.
Але це треба працювати годин дванадцять,
щоб зробити 40 штук.
Але кожен день по дванадцять годин
не дуже можливо так робити,
десь менше, десь більше.
А в середньому, якщо взяти,
то 30 ложок таких великих.
Менших можна 40 або навіть 50 зробити.
Тобто це можна зробити, але теоретично,
практично так ніколи не буває.
[сміється]
Така велика п'ятнадцять гривень [коштує],
а менша — десять або дванадцять.
Також є такі великі по десять гривень, це тепер.
Для сковорідок тощо.
Бо зараз сковорідки, в яких не можна
нічим металевим користуватись,
а тільки дерев'яним або пластиковим.
То переважно ложки, лопатки — це все йде для кухні.
Для сувенірів не знаю,
чи це може бути сувеніром.
Може бути, чому ні.
Всі [ложки] якраз ідуть за кордон.
Всі мої ложки якраз ідуть у Литву.
У Польщу і в Литву.
А так більше ніде.
Можливо колись будуть.
Може ми колись в Євросоюз [увійдемо],
десь за три роки потрапимо туди,
тоді вже можна буде напряму їхати,
продавати кудись в Іспанію [сміється].
Я їх просто виглажую,
щоб вони були більш гладенькими.
Вона трохи шорстка,
бо це такий папір [шліфувальний].
А так вона вже все — готова.
Якщо роблю з яблуні,
то покриваю їх звичайною олією.
Завдяки харчовій олії ложка міняє
структуру і стає темною.
У мене є один чоловік,
він сам з Косова [місто в Івано-Франківській області].
У нього брат живе в Литві,
і я йому вже років п'ятнадцять роблю, і він туди возить.
А потім приїхав інший чоловік з Литви.
Я йому зробив ці ложки, а то в Вільнюсі.
І той в Вільнюсі продає, й інший також.
А Зеник прийшов і каже:
«Перестань робити тому ложки, то мій конкурент».
А я кажу: «Звідки ти знаєш?»
«Як звідки знаєш, він що, не знає, де твої ложки?
Не впізнав?»
Той продає, а цей подивився, що це ж ці [ложки].
Так що не треба, має бути і так видно, що то моє.
[сміється]
Насправді, вони такі, що їх більше ніхто не робить.
Вони відрізняються від інших формою.